[Music]  Selena Gomez on the weekend step out  together again can't keep my hands to  myself check out this video of Selena  all smiles at Dave and Buster's with  tons of pals that's hanging out with  these kids et has learned the 24 year  old was at the arcade hot spot in  Hollywood for a private event with her  rumored new man to aren't in any pics  together but the weekend did pose for  this snap with French Montana and Jaden  Smith inside he also posted this shot of  Selena's photographer friend Ellie this  latest outing only further fuels of  dating rumors earlier this week they  took Ana John Mayer and Dave Chappelle  show together  [Music]  I'm in a good spot right now